so we talked about soil earlier and we
talked about the community community
sore community being a type of soil so
when you begin to plant the garden it
Ellis traits the importance of helping
others so you're working alongside a
community you're not going in to teach
me behind the garden again you're
facilitating so you're creating a space
you're being a resource because your
gardening yes but you're also
cultivating a space for a community to
learn from each other any excuse to get
people just interacting with a common
context I mean that's a great thing
about gardening right yeah I mean
there's just so much to talk about you
know and there's also a commitment to
providing a portion of the food to the
community so when you're planting you're
thinking about the types of foods and
how the food is going to be used in the
community and that's how you seen your
approach so we're using gardening to
help communities organized and develop
education efforts and because I'm an
intense gardener myself my grandmother
was a farmer and from Haiti and I i
remember my connection to the earth and
it was always a healing place for me and
I felt that the children needed a
healing place because of all the trauma
that they're suffering in the city that
are not accounted for that impact will
behavior and also that also impact the
learning ability the attention span and
I decided a little pilot project on my
own where I use my own money to I but
Cesar night and I but cups and a little
sticks for them to to label the seeds
and I created lessons around that for
them and how they can be inspired by the
ability of a seat to survive no matter
what if they have to go crew here to get
those funny they have to go under and we
appear to get the water the death
stepped on their growth flat it's just
it's too inspiring there's so much
learning that can really empower this
children if they can see the tenacity of
the dandelion that was my lesson
Gardens can be used as metaphors to
build partnerships between youth and
adults and so a garden is a great place
to bring in two generations of people to
talk about building community
you